Anakin
Hello there everyone this is going
to be my full obi-wan kenobi episode
2 video this is where the fun begins because
we finally saw hayden christensen come back as
darth vader anakin skywalker this is where the
fun begins there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
i'll explain what's going on with him in the
timeline so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes i
will be doing videos for all the episodes and
really quick shout out to my friends at raid
shadow legends who asked to sponsor this video
raid shadow legends is one of the biggest mobile
games in the world right now that's totally free
to play that's right it's free they wanted me to
tell you about some of their legendary champions
this month like ethos of the high elves and
cardio of the sacred order idos is a crit
monster he has a double primary attack that will
always crit and he's amazing for campaign farming
cardiel is more of a specialist who can raise
the entire team's crit rating and crit damage
and there's a ton happening in raid this month
with some new champions an update to tag arena in
a full schedule for special events and tournaments
but here's the main event raid's currently running
a special delaney chase event where you can get
your hands on the amazing deleona a brand new
legendary champion from the high elves faction
just by logging in all you have to do is log in
and play raid for seven days between now and
july 20th and you'll get deleon up for free
she's one of the strongest support champions in
the entire game and can help carry your team past
many of raid's tougher challenges so you don't
want to miss her once you're in the game new
players can enter the promo code my deleona to get
your hands on everything this is the best time to
get started in raid and if you use my link in the
description below or scan the qr code right here
that i'll put on screen in the video new players
will get a free starter pack worth almost 40
dollars to kickstart your game we're talking free
champions misericord tiger soul romero 10 magic
xp brew 10 force xp brew and 10 spirit xp brew all
that free stuff you can find in your inbox in the
upper right hand corner for the next 30 days so
be sure to check it out but careful for spoilers
from obi-wan kenobi episode 2 if you haven't seen
the episode yet we'll be talking about everything
i don't know if i'm getting into spoiler territory
here can i can i say anything that possibly gets
into spoiler territory here but just starting at
the beginning of the episode the actual opening
shot is of obi-wan kenobi ship landing on this
new casino looking planet daiyu it's meant to be
kind of like the space version of hong kong
during this episode he also calls again for
master qui-gon jinn's help making me think again
that he will show up in a cameo scene eventually
they also reveal our next big celebrity cameo
it's temura morrison coming back but as a cameo
scene for a clone trooper down on his luck
busking for change on the street as regular
stormtroopers walk by on the street just meant
to show you that during this part of the timeline
they were slowly phasing out all the clones they
were slowly dying off it was until closer to the
events of rogue one that most of the clones had
died out not all of them but most of the clones
i'm still kind of expecting torah morrison to come
back as rex during the ahsoka live action series
too like he could come back as many clones as you
want him to they set up the whole thing with him
using the spice to throw off the attackers later
in the episode by giving him that giant dose
you want to buy some death sticks you don't want
to sell me death sticks i don't want to sell your
death sticks you want to go home and rethink your
life i want to go home and rethink my life but the
dealer also mentions kessel pure glitter stem and
fellution felucia is a planet that shows up during
the clone wars and spice just in general has many
many different purposes and uses in the galaxy
most people just think about it as a drug though
but when people think about spice they think about
kessel they think about han solo solo a star wars
story takes place later in this timeline so as
these episodes are happening we haven't seen that
stuff play out yet the little kid winds up taking
him to hajja kumil nanjiani's character they have
this big funny scene with him pretending to be
a jedi and helping people escape planet but also
kind of stealing their money at the same time he's
meant to be like a scoundrel type character with a
heart of gold kind of like han solo like he tells
obi-wan kenobi i helped these people but i only
took a little bit of their money like their purse
is a little bit lighter that's all they have this
whole thing with obi-wan kenobi refusing to use
his jedi abilities though not using his lightsaber
he uses a blaster so uncivilized like everybody
just played the clip in their heads every time
they see him punch somebody or pull out a blaster
so uncivilized the whole idea as he says to young
leia is that he's trying to hide his abilities the
more he uses the force openly the more he outs
himself but most of this episode is meant to be
a big call to action like he is eventually forced
to use the force literally to save leia's life
you notice when he's scoping out the drug lab too
he starts playing with his mustache and his beard
twiddling it the same way that you see him doing
the prequels which is also meant to be a mirror
like a parallel trying to mimic alec guinnesses
obi-wan kenobi with the way he plays with his
beard in the original trilogy when he gets into
the hallway fight here this is a zabrak just like
darth maul just from a different part of their
race with a different color skin he's still a
zabrak though as far as they've said darth maul
isn't supposed to appear during this series but
he is alive in this part of the timeline in the
middle of running his crime syndicate then the
kidnappers reveal the trap that they set for him
is all about reva the other inquisitors trying
to get him they make this big deal about jedi
bleeding which i think is meant to be a reference
to how hardcore this series is compared to the way
they played his character during the prequels like
you don't actually see obi-wan kenobi bleed that
much during the prequels if at all in the idea
that again he's refusing to use his jedi abilities
like they literally just take his lightsaber right
off of him and punch him in the face but then they
try to play it against this funny joke about him
trying to save leia with her attacking him and
then questioning the whole situation just to
show you how smart how precocious she is at this
young age like she could potentially save herself
if things weren't quite so crazy it's also meant
to be evocative of the scene of luke skywalker
trying to rescue her on the death star when she
kind of took him to task and sassed him a little
bit before they took off like wait a minute aren't
you a little short for being a stormtrooper oh you
are here to save me okay let's go when they're
trying to escape the funny thing here is the
cloak that he puts her in this orange one is meant
to look just like the cloak that padme wore when
she was pretending to be one of her handmaidens
during phantom menace later in the episode when
they're in the hangar bay he also tells her you
remind me of a friend that i used to have no no
she died a long time ago just to say that she acts
just like her mother did that padme did nothing
you just remind me of someone she was fearless
too and stubborn the grand inquisitor shows up
with the other inquisitors to punish reva for
overstepping and stealing an imperial senator's
child they're all very evil but their alignment is
lawful evil they have a very clear sense of order
so like i said evil eventually defeating itself
it sounds like the inquisitors will take care of
each other eventually or somebody within the ranks
of the empire will help take care of them setting
up this whole idea that she is too quote unquote
ambitious for her own good and eventually that's
going to wind up force choking her in the ass like
maybe darth vader himself will wind up killing her
when she explains why she chose bail organa
because she sensed this connection between him and
obi-wan kenobi in the archive she's talking about
the jedi archives and the amount of information
they were able to steal from the jedi before the
jedi librarian and the other jedi were able to
destroy them so they have some of the information
contained in the jedi temple but not everything as
obi-wan kenobi explains to young leia during this
episode all the inquisitors are basically former
jedi or former padawans who are turned to the
dark side and are now hunting their own basically
like they had that whole intro during episode
one showing young reba as a padawan being trained
during order 66 while it was all going down just
to foreshadow her eventually being turned to the
dark side becoming an inquisitor for instance the
grand inquisitor actually used to be one of the
temple guardians at the jedi temple on coruscant
he was one of the people at ahsoka tano's trial
and he took a lot of that to heart and felt
like the jedi were actually leading him down
the wrong path so that by the time that order 66
came along he actually made the decision to turn
to the dark side and help the emperor so that's
when he became the grand inquisitor effectively
when he tries to throw shade on reva about how
she came from the gutter and they only took her
in basically to their ranks because of her jedi
abilities they're just trying to reference that
they basically took any force sensitives they
could find and twisted them to the dark side
it's also meant to dovetail with what you saw
from leia's cousins like her cousins don't
seemingly care about normal people as much as they
should the way that the other inquisitors are very
elitist and they don't care about less fortunate
people like oh you come from the wrong side of the
railroad tracks the only reason we're letting you
stay here is because you have some force abilities
also setting up a huge rivalry between the rest
of them you notice the picture that she circulates
around the planet is of obi-wan during revenge of
the sith because his beard is way more kempt there
are a couple funny jokes that young leia tells
obi-wan kenobi about how he looks so old i think
that's just meant to dovetail with why he looks so
old during a new hope in the alec guinness version
because ewan mcgregor still looks almost the exact
same like he hasn't aged a day but he's meant to
look like alec guinness within a couple years time
span like not a lot of time goes by before a new
hope so they're just joking about that when she's
like oh you look old enough to be my grandfather
a lot of you asking about this assassin droid that
you saw during the trailers this isn't meant to be
for loam it's just a similar type of droid it's
a brand new character though when he tells young
leia that her father is a very old friend of
his he's not lying because both bail organa and
anakin skywalker were good friends of his in the
whole thing with her running off on her own it's
just trying to show you how resourceful she is
trying to save herself but also force obi-wan
kenobi's hand and make him use his jedi abilities
they also use a lot of this chase to show you some
of reva's force abilities too camille's hajja
character winds up helping them out pointing
them towards this planet called mapuzo it's
a planet in the mid rim because a lot of this
takes place in and around the mid rim then they
have that funny scene with him trying to stall
reva and her using her force abilities to pull the
information of obi-wan's whereabouts from his mind
they just want to show you that she does have
some skills like it's not all meant to be talk
and bluster they have the grand inquisitor kill
fleas character r.i.p with that double-bladed
lightsaber it works just like you saw during
star wars rebels with the hilt spinning around
obi-wan kenobi would probably have some funny
things to say about that criticizing it like
that seems like a flashy lightsaber hill you don't
need to spin around and do all those crazy things
then this whole scene of reva versus obi-wan
kenobi with her stalking him talking about his
fear betraying him is meant to be a reference
to darth vader stalking hunting luke skywalker
on the second death star during their big fight
scene just playing cat and mouse with him trying
to get inside his head she also references darth
vader verbally and anakin skywalker for the first
time in the series 201 kenobi and it's meant to be
this huge wtf moment the way they play it like a
big reaction on his part because previously he had
thought that anakin skywalker had died on mustafar
that's why he freaks out so bad when he hears
that the other big reveal here too is that reva
and apparently the other inquisitors know that
darth vader used to be anakin skywalker and within
the empire that was meant to be a relatively big
secret even grand moff tarkin said that he truly
did not know for certain whether or not darth
vader used to be anakin skywalker he suspected he
was but he wasn't sure about it i think what they
might be doing on this series is just saying that
she knows that anakin skywalker used to be darth
vader probably because she was a padawan and would
have seen him at the jedi temple and probably
heard some rumors about it behind the scenes
just because only a couple people within the
empire had actually confirmed the news that he'd
become darth vader doesn't mean that there weren't
a lot of suspicions and a lot of rumors being
passed around the inquisitors would have also
had access to a lot of information that regular
imperials would not have had access to but just
to give you an idea for how private he was exactly
very few people actually ever saw him without the
armor on so like even though reva talks about him
being anakin skywalker she probably has not
seen him underneath the armor even though i
think what they'll do is they'll show obi-wan
kenobi eventually wounding him so that you see
his helmet kind of broken the way that you see
during rebels so that you can tell that it's
hayden christensen's anakin skywalker underneath
the armor there would have been no reason for them
to actually bring hayden christensen back
if they weren't going to actually show him
anakin skywalker underneath the armor that's the
reason you bring him back she also tries to kill
the grand inquisitor by running in through his
chest with the lightsaber but remember the grand
inquisitor doesn't die to the events of star wars
rebels way later in the timeline so unless they're
doing a big retcon here i think that he'll wind
up surviving this encounter like he'll show up
in later episodes they'll reveal that he survived
also i think the whole existence of darth vader
just in general being able to survive even though
it takes a lot of technology to help him survive
is more evidence that the grand inquisitor could
potentially survive this body shot there is still
good in him he's more machine now than man but
remember the inquisitors don't know anything about
leia or luke's real identity even though they
know that anakin skywalker is darth vader that
scene of her twisting that knife in obi-wan kenobi
metaphorically is also meant to be evocative of
darth vader twisting the idea of leia inside luke
oh if you won't turn then maybe your sister that's
right your sister can be turned later in the
transport as he's still in shock he actually says
the name anakin out loud still freaking out over
the reveal as they cut to the shot of darth vader
hayden christensen himself stewing in his back the
tank opening his eyes in his castle on mustafar
in that same chamber that you saw during rogue
one for those of you asking if darth vader was
actually sensing obi-wan kenobi and leia through
the force he didn't actually learn that leia was
really his daughter or her true identity until
the events of return of the jedi he might have had
suspicions early on but he didn't actually confirm
it until return of the jedi when he's having that
conversation with luke so it is possible that
he felt a disturbance in the force because both
of them were there but he might not have totally
understood what he was sensing through the force
like he was powerful but he couldn't pinpoint
obi-wan kenobi exactly where he was on that daiyu
planet leaving if he'd been able to do that he
would have been able to sense him a long time ago
but a lot of that gets into obi-wan kenobi hiding
his force abilities not using the force grogu was
doing the same thing as a way to hide himself from
the emperor and darth vader the other inquisitors
like i said i think they're only going to flirt
with the idea that the inquisitors might wind up
finding out who luke and leia are but they don't
actually find out or maybe someone like reva finds
out and then as she tries to turn good and help
obi-wan kenobi then darth vader kills her before
she can reveal leia's true identity or luke's
true identity somehow they will find a way to
preserve the timeline so that he doesn't actually
find out till later so the whole idea is that in
episode 3 next week we'll probably see him back in
the armor way more actual darth vader scenes and
they'll probably have a couple encounters during
the series the way they talk about it they won't
just be one rematch like they'll see each other
encounter each other a couple different times
obi-wan kenobi also almost used his lightsaber
during episode two i think that they'll wait
to have him actually use his lightsaber till
later on when he actually confronts darth vader
but like i said the whole thing this last 10
years is that darth vader has been trying to find
obi-wan kenobi that's been the biggest thing
on his mind they also revealed that he's slowly
been trying to kill the anakin skywalker
identity within himself like there is this
small light of goodness within him as he's slowly
trying to deepen his connection to the dark side
of the force he's basically trying to extinguish
everyone the anakin skywalker used to be within
himself but i think part of the idea with the
title of episode 4 a new hope is that something
will happen in his encounters with obi-wan kenobi
his rematches that will help lead that spark that
will eventually bloom into something during return
of the jedi where he does turn good again and kill
the emperor or try to kill the emperor to save
luke skywalker but even though this episode
just focuses on them going to tatooine to try and
find obi-wan kenobi and these are the rogue jedi
that's basically what they've been doing for
the last 10 years even though he's mostly been
looking for obi-wan kenobi they've also been busy
hunting many many other jedi survivors and other
force sensitives around the galaxy or a younger
child like the one that the mother was trying
to save that hajja helped during the episode even
though he took their money they'll basically take
that kid and then try to twist them to the dark
side and raise them as another inquisitor so the
whole idea is that if hajja had not saved them
even though he stole their money that kid would
wind up being just like the grand inquisitor just
like the fifth brother just like reva eventually
and if that wasn't clear they actually did imply
that that little kid was force sensitive and that
was the reason why the mother was so willing to
pay all that money to get them off a planet but
if you spotted any other big easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments my full
obi-wan kenobi episode 3 video will post next
week just like normal and big reminder the normal
episodes will air on wednesdays instead of fridays
they only did it special this week because star
wars celebration was happening this weekend it'll
go back to normal next week and there are six
episodes total there are a bunch of other trailer
videos like the andor trailer i did a video for
it so i'll post a link in the description below
so you can watch that but they also have the
mandalorian season 3 trailer with a bunch of
new footage my full easter egg video for that
will post next on saturday after they released
the mandalorian season 3 trailer online so that
should happen pretty soon make sure you enable
orders for my channel so you don't miss that mando
and grogu going all the way back to the scene of
the crime going back to the planet mandalore a lot
of the throne room of mandola that you see during
clone wars at the very end of that series during
season seven shows up during the mandalorian
season three trailer everyone click here for my
full obi-wan kenobi episode 1 video in easter eggs
and click here for my mandalorian season 3 trailer
video i'll update the link as soon as i post that
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!